hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar hemoglobinopathy testing what
are the key points a lab should consider
my name is dr matthew c wagner of sabia
electrophoresis and i'll be your
moderator for today today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by fabia
electrophoresis to learn more visit
www.sabia.com
or sebia.usa.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr case harteveld from leiden university
medical center in the netherlands dr
harteveld you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you very much dr wagner for
your nice introduction
i'd like to tell you something about
my daily work so the hemoglobinopathy
diagnostics
hemoglobin is the most important protein
for oxygen transport and the red blood
cells erythrocytes are filled with
hemoglobin which is a tetrameric protein
and the majority is hemoglobin a
consisting of two alpha globin chains
and two beta globin chains
they form a tetramer
um
besides this almost 97.5 percent of
hemoglobin a the cells also contain
hemoglobin a2 which is alpha 2 delta 2.
the delta globin chain is very much like
the beta-globin chain but it is coded
for by a different gene
these these globin chains are
synthesized
because of the expression of
the globin genes
and the globin genes are very much alike
they all consist of three axons and two
introns
and they are located in so-called gene
families or gene clusters
the beta globin chain is coded by the
beta gene which is located on the short
arm
11.
and the alpha globin chains are coded
for by two alpha genes located on the
short arm of chromosome 16 and during
evolution the
alpha genes have been duplicated
so together the two alpha genes together
they are responsible for the synthesis
of the alpha chains in an equal ratio as
the beta the single beta is for the
beta globin so there is a balance
between the alpha and beta globin
globin chain synthesis
diseases which are related to hemoglobin
are thalassemia and sickle cell disease
which are i think
the major ones
so thalassemia is due to a defect of
expression of
the beta gene or the alpha gene
now the beta gene defect
gives beta thalassemia major which is
the most common disease phenotype and
this is due to the malfunctioning of two
beta genes
so the expression is uh severely reduced
and the alpha globin chains are in
excess they may form tetramers with
themselves which are
not soluble
and they precipitate destroy the
membrane and this causes hemolysis
and an ineffective irritable eases
and this is the basis of the disease
um
sickle cell disease
the other disease related to the beta
gene is due to a missense mutation and
homozygous for the missense mutation in
which a
valine is um
substituted for where normally there
would be a glutaminic acid
you get
s
which is alpha 2 beta s2
and
this hemoglobin s forms polymers at low
ph or low oxygen tension
and this means that the hemoglobin um is
actually
um making polymers so from
a
solution it becomes solid
and this distorts the uh
red blood cells giving the
characteristic sickle cell shape
and this also means that the human the
irretrosites lose their flexibility so
they can cause obstruction of the small
vesicles
and this goes with an intense pain the
so-called sickle cell crisis
these disease states
of hemoglobin opti are recessive which
means
that you have to inherit both defects
from both parents in order to get or
develop the disease
carriers on the other hand in which
there's only one defective gene
are clinically silent
and they can function normally
beta thalassemia trait
is the condition in which there's only
one beta gene
or half of the alpha genes maximum
not
able to synthesize globin chains
and those
situation is only recognized by a very
mild anemia
the sickle cell trait it is even less
you have a completely normal hematology
and you have to do either hblc or
capillary electrophoresis to identify a
carrier of the hemoglobin s for instance
now why are there so many
because almost seven percent of the
world population appears to be carrier
of a form of hemoglobinopathy
but this has everything to do with this
uh plasmodium falciparum
which is um
parasite living in in the guts of the
anovalus the malaria mosquito
and part of the reproductive cycle
is taking place in the guts of the
anophelus and part is taking place in
the bloods of a a human
recipient
so in this case it appears that carriers
of thalassemia or carriers of s
have a selective advantage
over non-carriers in being able to surv
a malaria infection
so
especially at young age when many
children die
of
malaria these areas seem to be protected
against death by malaria
however the consequence of being a
carrier is that two carriers can have a
child which is a thalassemia major or
sickle cell disease
more than 350 000 babies are born each
year with sickle cell anemia and
thalassemia major due to the fact that
there are so many carriers
and
the areas indicated in this map in red
are the areas where where malaria
tropica is endemic
however
people tend to migrate
in hundreds of years and in this way
also
previously
um non-endemic
areas become
endemic for hemoglobinopathy as well so
carius can be found everywhere in the
world
the prevention and management of
hemoglobin hemoglobinopathy consists of
the implementation of basic health
interventions
so management of sickle cell disease for
instance
starts with an early diagnosis
then penicillin prophylaxis and
vaccination
and this all to reduce the excess
mortality amongst children under five
years
management of thalassemia major consists
also of early diagnosis to start blood
transfusions and chelation therapy
collation therapy is necessary to
prevent
the
the effects of iron accumulation because
of the high
transfusion regime in which let's say
milligrams of iron are introduced into
the body
by each transfusion and don't leave the
body that easily so you need to do
something to get rid of that excess of
iron
and this is all to prevent unnecessary
complications of treatment
the prevention of sickle cell anemia and
glycemia major plays a role in many
endemic countries
they
do carrier detection
and
they provide information and counseling
to couples at risk in which both parents
are carrier and this is all to also to
to
offer prenatal diagnosis of course if
that is legally permitted and that is
not the matter in all states
in some countries
there is a premarital screening and an
advice not to marry in case of a carrier
situation in both parents but in the
netherlands
we offer also prenatal diagnosis for
this disease as in many european
countries and endemic countries like
italy greece turkey et cetera
and this is to reduce the number of
affected births
hemoglobinopathies is one of the few
genetic diseases which can be prevented
by screening carriers
usually carriers
of genetic diseases can only be detected
at a molecular level and screening dna
dna levels often very expensive or
complicated however
carriers of hemoglobinopathy are healthy
but they are recognized at the
hematological level
and as you probably all know if you are
a little bit
let's say tired you go to your general
practitioner you often get a blood
investigation and
the values of that are automatically
determined in most laboratories so
every clinical geneticist or clinical
chemist can actually see if someone is a
carrier of a thalassemia especially when
the iron level is normal
so carriers are easy to recognize at the
hematological level and that is mainly
carriers of thalassemia
carriers of sickle cell disease
c and d etc they are recognized at the
level of hemoglobin typing so hplc or
capillary electrophoresis
carriers
can be
cancelled preconceptionally that is the
best method to do or the best moments
but it can also be done at the first
intake
at pregnancy like is done in the united
kingdom
a third option is neonatal screening but
of course the baby is already born and
sickle cell disease is already
found but if you could also
identify carriers in this way and that
is possible technically and you would
report back to the parents that the baby
is a carrier you could prevent an
affected birth for a second pregnancy
many provincial programs
they concentrate on career screening and
providing genetic information
counselling of couples at risk
offering prenatal diagnosis and optional
prevent birth of an affected child
the hemoglobin switch is an important
thing to understand if you want to know
what hemoglobin
types you can see at the
separation level so if you are using a
capillary electrophoresis or hplc for
detecting hemoglobinopathies it's good
to know about the switch
hemoglobin switch shown in this graph
indicates that the genes which are
located in order of expression on the
short arm of chromosome 16 in the alpha
global gene cluster and on the short arm
of chromosome 11
the beta globin gene cluster
is that
actually there is a different uh
expression genes expressed at a
different stage
of development
and also in a different tissue
so first you have the expression of zeta
and epsilon in the embryonic phase
and that is as you can see in the graph
the expression of zeta and epsilon go
down rapidly because these genes are
switched off and the alpha gene on the
other hand is switched on and
for the beta is the gamma which are
switched on so during the whole field
fetal period you have expression of
alpha and gamma
and this forms hemoglobin f
f is alpha to gamma two
around birth you see a steep switching
off of the gamma genes and a switching
on of the beta genes
which
is responsible for let's say the
synthesis of beta-globin and which forms
with alpha-globin the hemoglobin a adult
hemoglobin a and later on you see also
hemoglobin a2 coming up
this is happening in a period after
birth
up to
let's say six months after birth you
have a complete expression of hemoglobin
a and you have our hardly any hemoglobin
hat
remaining hemoglobin f so this also
means that if you have a problem with
your beta gene
the disease is going to be expressed six
months after birth or one year after
birth when the
hemoglobin is totally
dependent on the expression of the beta
gene
so
at six months or one year you can expect
the first crisis to occur in case of
sickle cell disease
or you get this severe anemic situation
in beta thalassemia major
now what is the best moment or the best
way to detect uh thalassemia and sickle
cell disease carriers well there's
three components in the lab which are
play an important role
and that is the red cell hematology
the hemoglobin typing and the dna
conformation
and this
together
will tell you the story if the phenotype
fits
or that you have to do more
so for the retinal hematology we go into
detail in the next slide
we measure the hemoglobin content the
red blood cell count the text cell
volume which is in my language
hematocrit
and the mcv and mch
for hemoglobin typing it's important to
determine the percentage of hemoglobin
a2
to distinguish beta thalassemia carrier
the percentage of hemoglobin x that
could be s or c or d or any of the more
than 1200 hemoglobin variants that we
know about
and hemoglobin f the remaining fetal
hemoglobin
and dna confirmation can be found by
using techniques like senger sequencing
the genes for
alpha and beta are very small so it's
reasonably easy to sequence them
completely
including the regulatory elements intons
and exons
gap pcr which is a
way to detect the lesions common or
known deletions mainly alpha thalassemia
deletions
and mlpa which is a technique to
determine uncommon or rare deletions or
duplications
and this reaches the high sensitivity
most cases of
carriership
can be solved using these three elements
now let's first look into the hematology
i have here depicted the hemoglobin
percentage gram percents
in the first column you see the normal
men and women
the second
you see
the carrier and in the last column you
see the patient with beta thalassemia
and we are looking in fact
for
red cells which are smaller than usual
and more deprived of hemoglobin than
usual so microcytic hyperchromic red
cells
we do that by measuring the mcv which is
the mean cellular volume
in the normal situation
it's about
between let's say 85 and 95
but in carriers you see it is much lower
so the red cells are smaller than usual
there's a large overlap however with
patience
if we look at the mch that is the
graphic below this one you see that
there is also
a
large distinction
between the normal and the carrier
of beta thalassemia and you see that the
mch is considerably lower so if let's
say the red cell is more
has less hemoglobin so it is
less colored under the microscope you
could say
if we go to the left you see the red
blood cell count and now we see
something remarkable
if you look at the red blood cell count
in the normal in comparison to the
carrion you see that the carrier has
much more red cells
and this
makes that the hemoglobin is in fact
which is above it the hemoglobin is in
fact very comparable with the normal
situation
so this means that there is a kind of
anticipation of the body where the
carrier
has let's say smaller red cells and
more deprived of hemoglobin but
there are many more of them so this
compensates and you have
quite a good hemoglobin which
makes that you can do your work
this however does not account for the
patients the red blood cells are lower
than normal and that's because of the
hemolysis you lose red cells because of
the excess of alpha globin chains
of course i could tell you the same
story for alpha thalassemia however
because we have four alpha genes you can
either miss one two three or even all
four of them so you have more categories
that's why you see
let's say more columns
and if you look at increasing
number of of well increasing uh uh
clinical significance
so let's say less alpha gene expression
then you see that the hemoglobin goes
down mcp goes down and ch goes down and
the red blood cell goes up
the red blood cell count goes up to a
certain point where the hemolysis is
going to take over and then you see that
the red blood cell counts are going down
and that is of course in the patients
with hemoglobin age disease
and last we have well not last a second
we have the hb typing so we use in our
laboratory both hplc and capillary
electrophoresis and i'll go into detail
about that later on in the cases
you can actually distinguish very easily
a normal pattern from a pattern with an
hemoglobin variant or a beta
thalassaemia carrier when the hemoglobin
k2 level is elevated
dna analysis or confirmation is done by
a system called get pcr we have
several primers to detect the eight most
common alpha thalassemia deletions and
by a simple agarose gel electrophoresis
we can identify the different deletions
very easily
if that is negative and we still have a
suspicion based on the hematology we can
do sequencing of the complete alpha and
complete beta globin genes and we do the
same if we see in hemoglobin variants
because the variance can be either an
alpha variant or beta variant so we we
sequence the alpha genes and the beta
genes they are relatively small
so in four overlapping fragments we can
sequence the complete
uh
gene
and if that does not provide the answer
there might be a deletion at stake and
we detect this with multiplex ligation
dependent probe amplification
abbreviated as mlpa
here you can see copy number variations
both deletions but also duplications of
certain gene areas
now how does capillary electrophoresis
and hplc fit into the diagnosis of
hemoglobinopathy
well here are some common separations
and
the upper part you see in hplc in the
lower part of capillary electrophoresis
of the same patient every time so if we
look at the left the normal gives a
hemoglobin a and a2
and 97.5 percent about and 2.5 percent
if the a2 is elevated this is typical
for beta thalassemia trait and if you
have for instance hemoglobin f in an
adult then this is usually due to a
deletion taking away delta and beta
thalassemia
as you can see hplc separates
differently from the capillary
electrophoresis so if you have
hemoglobin variants which you can't see
with one technique you can probably see
it with the other one so they are
complementary let's say
here
are some other examples of common
hemoglobin variants worldwide that is
for instance carriers of hemoglobin c
and you can see immediately that c
separates differently from s
and also differently from d even though
s and d they are let's say almost in the
same zone but they are
separate one is in the z5 zone and the
other in the desert six zone so they are
distinguishable
however
how sure are you if you see a
peak in a certain zone
how sure can you be that it is
indeed hemoglobin s for instance
if you have two separation methods
that is already let's say
helping a lot because we have different
separation techniques one is affinity
chromatography and the other is a
base charge
but you have also a conformation test
like sickle cell test so it's the sickle
cell test it's positive you know that it
is
let's say
there's hemoglobin s and likewise you
can have hemoglobin c which is different
but then confirmation needs to be done
on dna level
and especially in these cases when
separation patterns are much more
complex you need dna
and
you need also have some background in
genetics
genetics is fortunately
very simple even though if you look at
this graph you might doubt my words that
it is simple because there are a lot of
hemoglobin
genes and a lot of proteins which can
exist however we can simplify this
so in adults you just have the four
alpha genes to take into account the two
beta genes and the two delta genes so
what is the maximum
of glutens you can make from these well
actually
uh hemoglobin a the most common one and
hemoglobin a2 so this are all the
tetramers which you can make
from
this um
from these combinations
and if you have a carrier of s
you will see an extra peak appearing and
that is hemoglobin s which is about 40
percent in a normal carrier
now
alpha thalassemia is one of those
tyler schemas you can identify easily in
a carrier of s
without doing dna analysis almost
so if you look at the normal
s carrier usually the hemoglobin s is 40
about
however if there is a single alpha gene
defect
uh you see every
that the s
percentage is lower it lowers up to 35
percent about and if you have two alpha
gene defects
then you either insist or in trance you
see that the hemoglobin s goes down to
about 25 to 30 percent and that is
very well distinguishable with capillary
electrophoresis
the hplc you can also see it but it is
because of the the let's say the
baseline which is less stable hplc it's
more difficult to to see it but
capillary electrophoresis is
it's very well visible you can almost
put
a line
to see that there is actually
also alpha thalassemia playing a role
okay i'll go through the cases now i
have seven cases uh one case is the
genotype phenotype
um correlation uh in this
african male
he has microcytic hyperchromic anemia we
see a lot of of um
peaks
and dna analysis shows us that this
patient is homozygous for the so-called
3.7 deletion a rightward deletion
which means that he is missing one alpha
gene on each allele
and on top of it he has a point mutation
in one of these
causing g philadelphia that is the
let's say this the protein which is uh
uh due to a substitution of
amino acids so g philadelphia is called
and here's s carrier which is probably
not a surprise because of this african
origin so if we look at this
picture and determine how many different
hemoglobin types you can predict
from this composition
of dna well at least the normal ones so
the hemoglobin
a
from alpha and beta hemoglobin s alpha
to beta s2 and alpha 2 delta s2 but of
course also that philadelphia can form
these combinations with beta beta s and
delta
so in total you have six different
hemoglobin types and all of them you can
trace back on the pattern you see on the
left side
so in this way
it is
all you can see that all the hemoglobin
types are there and you can easily
understand
well sometimes you have bad luck and you
may miss something with your hplc
like in this case
you see on the right
uh the hplc pattern and we see actually
a completely normal pattern but on the
left using capillary electrophoresis we
see a
small peak just in front of the a
and this is due to an
alpha variance this alpha variant
of alpha one
so in principle you can expect the
normal hemoglobin a in hemoglobin a2 but
also the alpha variance of the let's say
alpha beta and the alpha delta so there
is also an extra a2 and in fact if you
look carefully you can see here the a2
peak but there's also a very small peak
here which added up is giving the total
hemoglobin a2
this is hemoglobin nuage it is visible
on ce but not on hplc and it is an alpha
1 variant
on hemoglobin var it indicates that
the the website where the incoming
variants are presented
it is 25
it's it's unusually hydrophobic and no
clinical consequences are related to it
well we have seen two dutch families
with this hemoglobin nuage and that
gives about nine percent of humans
second case here you see it as a male
with a slightly microcytic hyperchromic
anemia
and we see uh
let's say a distinctive peak
uh between the a and the a2 on the
capillary electrophoresis
but the
the hplc shows more a little bit strange
peak here it is actually under the a
it's hemoglobin atlanta it's visible on
caprioelectoresis but not really on hplc
so it would be missed easily on hplc and
this is an unstable hemoglobin variant
giving mild hemolytic anemia in the
carrier
but it could also be the other way
around unfortunately so something
like this you can see it completely
normal capillary electric resist pattern
and now the hplc shows something strange
and this is the
uh
hemoglobin santa guana it's a very rare
one
but uh it is uh
a hemoglobin variant of the beta chain
and it gives about 10 percent but this
is a
bad estimation because of the high
peak underneath
and this is due to the overlap
it's a hemoglobin variance in which the
oxygen oxygen affinity is decreased
gives mild anemia and is found mainly in
mexicans and greek
for a hemoglobin monopoly reference lab
it is therefore convenient to have both
capillary electrophoresis and hplc
however all common clinically relevant
hemoglobin variants like hemoglobin s c
d e etc separate very well on capillary
electropieces or on hplc so you don't
need both necessarily
well this is an example in which we see
a double peak in the capillary
electrophoresis so there is a split
a peak here and hplc shows it in a
better separation and this is due to a
beta variance
and this beta variant is hemoglobin
hounslow
the codon 80 is changed and you see a
tyrosine in sediment aspirin
and this
is present in about 38 percent in the
heterozygous it is uh
originates from afghanistan and it gives
a normal clinical presentation so in
this case there's no clinical
consequences and also no genetic
consequence
hemoglobin variants sometimes travel
around the world
and
i want would like to show you an example
of this one this is hemoglobin
hemoglobin molmer is a beta variant
um in which a
alpha bond beta2 contact is disrupted
because of the substitution of the
histidine for a glutaminic acid a
glutamine sorry
um
this
goes with the uh
erythrocytosis
so the
and we also have a dutch family
however it was firstly described in the
swedish family
and probably you have you recognize
these fellows
these are vikings and they come from
sweden and in the year thousands and
nine hundreds they they
raided the coastal areas of of europe
um and left their genes there
and they burned uh everything to the
ground
and dragged home all um
[Music]
or valuables so so this this hemoglobin
from uh
the increased oxygen affinity causing
polycythemia was maybe of some benefit
to these gentlemen because they were
let's say more highly and
well
they they could let's say binder oxygen
very very well and maybe they had the
possibility to
to go on um forever and ever
however this hemoglobin mulmer has also
a disadvantage and that is that carriers
often experience that say headaches or
uh and bleeding of this is is helping
just to to reduce the breath cell volume
now hemoglobin malmo was first described
in the swedish family but it was also
found in the netherlands
uh also in england from a saxon family
and
from a french family uh coming from
brittany
and
last but not least in sicily and what
many people don't know is that the
vikings actually reached sicily and had
a kingdom there for over 200 years so in
this way you can almost trace back
the root of the
vikings by looking at the hemoglobin
sometimes the hemoglobin variant is very
unstable and therefore not detectable at
a protein level this causes a beta-tyler
seen a trait phenotype as it happens in
the hemoglobin or in the beta gene
you'll notice an elevated hemoglobin a2
like in the case of hemoglobin showa
yakushi that sounds very japanese and it
was also firstly described in a japanese
female
also in a japanese family there was a
programmed mother and sister and an
unrelated japanese individual
later hemoglobin showa yakushi was also
found in some families from west india
but we found it in a dutch
family
originating from a small village near
the dutch coast and many coastal
villages there were
sailors and sailors
they
um
were going around the world let's say
and especially in the dutch east indian
company
time into the 16th and 17th century
there were a lot of settlements of the
dutch east indian company in the
different countries where trading was
happening
also in japan
um
here are some characteristics the uh
gives hemolytic anemia in the carrier
and the elevated a2 is very typical so
it looks like a beta thalassemia trait
phenotype but actually it's an unstable
hemoglobin
and
it gives
let's say beta plus thalassemia
now
the question which arose was is this
hemoglobin
which happens to
much but also in the japanese and the
west bengali have they some association
with each other are they
the founder maybe
but how did it come about so could it be
a rare dutch hemoglobin maybe variant
traveling to japan or west india or the
other way around
and for this uh question you need to
determine the haplotype and the
hepatotype of the japanese
[Music]
hemoglobin show a yakushi mutation was
determined now i have to tell you that
the dutch were actually traders and
japan was at in the 16th 17th century
very closed the emperor did not allow
strangers on japanese ground so he
had a island constructed an artificial
island in in front of the coast
and the dutch were supposed to stay
there
and
just to prevent them from escaping
uh he
the
um
emperor sent
to
this
uh settlement
guys were
japanese ladies
and marriage came about
between the
the um people from the company and and
the geisha
and also children who are born
there are let's say there's historical
information for that
however when the uh
employee had to return home to the
netherlands he was not allowed to take
his wife and children written
so that means that the let's say gene
flow was actually
from holland to japan and not the other
way around
in theory
so um we investigated the hepatite of
the west indian um
well the west indian sample was already
investigated and the haplotype was
published and it was different
from
the
japanese haplotype however the dutch and
the japanese hypertypes were identical
but this identical hepatite was the most
common
so there's still
an a large chance that it was purely
coincidental that the mutation occurred
twice
on independent genetic backgrounds
but
a founder of facts might also be
possible we don't know uh historical
proof is lacking
so we don't know whether this ought to
be a hemoglobin voc
from the dutch indian company
abbreviation
but i think we should stick at the showa
yakushi
talking about elevated a2
there are a lot of stories going on
about the importance of hemoglobin a2 we
know it's from the beta thalassemia
carrier but also many people ask
is
if if
beta thalassemia straight has elevated
a2 does that mean that alpha thalassemia
trait goes with a decreased hemoglobin
a2 well from this picture you can see
that actually iron
is um lowering the the a2 iron depletion
um however the alpha is not really
affected the a2 is not really affected
that much there's still a large overlap
with the normal controls
when you lack the expression of one or
two alpha genes if you let the
expression of three alpha genes then it
is reduced
but then you also see hemoglobin h
so
i don't see really that much added value
to the hemoglobin a2
in the relationship of
diagnosing alpha thalassemia
of course without doubt elevated a2 goes
with the beta thalassaemia trait even in
the presence of alpha thalassemia or in
the presence of typical that does not
really influence the a2 very much
on the other hand
if you have a beta thalassemia in
combination the delta thalassemia
then the a2 goes back to normal and then
you will probably
consider this as a microcytic
hyperchromic anemia that normally to
representing an alpha thalassemia but
in fact it's a combination of delta and
beta thalassemia
there are also some
beta variants which go with a
almost normal a2
come back to that here
you see here a group of let's say
normals in red
this gives a normal a2 and elevated a2
these are beta thalassemia trait
confirmed by dna analysis however you
also see a kind of overlap
and if we focus on the overlap it
appears that these are all
elevated or almost a two
situations
uh of a particular type of
beta variance of beta thalassemia
mutation they are listed here so the
idea is one six d2c the plus one minus
101 etc these are all mutations in which
which given heterozygote only a very
tiny elevated a2 so they can easily be
overlooked
so an elevated a2 can also be
inconclusive and that's this case uh
k6
is that the beta thalassemia traits seen
in these
persons in this family
have an elevated a2 a microcytic
hyperchromic anemia
however there is no mutation found in
the beta gene
so
they are
we have looked at the alpha beta chain
synthesis ratio and that was uh let's
say disturbed in one of the uh
family members
so it is a true beta thalassemia
according to the definition but there is
no mutation in the visa gene
moreover from whole exome sequencing we
also found that there was no correlation
with the beta-globin gene cluster there
was however a correlation with the gene
called subt5h
and this
subt5h
is
showing a mutation in the splice donor
site and then the other family despite
acceptor site which gives on rna an uh
an intra partial internal retention and
therefore a disruption of the reading
frame
so the protein is in fact shortened in
the most important region here you can
see the c-terminus of this protein
except sput-5 protein is the product of
substitute h
and that is let's say
not made in these in these carriers
and this protein plays a part
in the dsif complex and this deceptive
complex is about activator and repressor
of transcription elongation
so if the phosphorylation cannot take
place because of the absence of these
repetitive area on the c-terminus
you get that it is blocked and this
might be the reason why these people
haven't elevated a2 and let's say a
typical beta thalassemia traits we don't
know for sure
but um
[Music]
animal studies like in zebrafish
indicate that this lumen spit 5 is
active in the hematopoietic
irritable with poet-specific
region
um and and and tissue and that it is
also playing a role in gather one
induction and from gatto one it is known
that it plays a very important role in
the regulation of the beta gene
in the meantime we have found
eight different subt5h mutations in 25
persons
all showing this unknown beta
thalassemia trait phenotype
and all these eight mutations are null
alleles so they just
are
do not allow
the
the expression because of flame shift
mutations or stop mutations
last case is a one which we obtained
from neonatal screening you can see the
switch here this is the around birth the
normal situation you have in the baby
the active alpha genes the beta genes
and the delta is not active yet
and we have the gamma
which is expressed and gives hemoglobin
f so around birth a normal baby is about
80 hemoglobin f and some 20 hemoglobin a
now
we
um if you have
a single alpha gene defect we see that
there is a
relatively excess of gamma
which cannot find an alpha partner let's
say
so they start forming gamma tetramers
itself hemoglobin bars
in a very low percentage but in
let's say the neonatal screening that is
a good marker for the presence of alpha
thalassemia
i tell you this to understand bats at
the following case
we found this baby in
the neonatal screening in collaboration
with amphia hospital in
breida
in the netherlands and this is a
strange pattern
this baby
was 18 days old when it was presented
and we did dna analysis of this one and
there appear to be three defects
one is the 4.2 deletion which is
a
so-called network deletion it takes away
one alpha gene and on top of it there
was the hemoglobin q-tylene mutation so
on that allele there was also
a missense mutation so this gives a
chain the so-called q-tile and alpha-q
thailand chain
from this allele
and
the baby was carrier of hemoglobin e
which is very common in thailand and
cambodia vietnam etc so in east asia
so if we look at this composition
and estimate uh how many different
hemoglobins tetramers can be formed with
this
genetic composition
you can see that you have the normal
alpha with the beta the normal alpha
with the beta e
the
q alpha q thailands with the beta e and
with the normal beta and of course you
have your gamma still because that is
still expressed after birth so you are a
normal hemoglobin f
and your q thailand hemoglobin f
and besides that you also have the
hemoglobin bars
okay
and do we find this back well in fact
you see six different peaks and there
are seven different
tetramers
and the reason is that the
fq thailand
is actually of the let's say the normal
hemoglobin f coincides with the two
tyrants hemoglobin so they're on the
same position
so they go together and that's why the
so-called f peak is not really f it is f
and q times
we look at the next slide
this is the situation of the same baby
but then at 87 days after birth and you
see as changing of the pattern this is
of course
visualizing the switch
because in the meantime
the delta is come up the gamma
expression goes down and the beta is
going up so now you have not anymore the
hemoglobin bars because that disappears
in such a mild alpha thalassemia but you
have the appearance of hemoglobin a2 and
the hemoglobin q-tylene a2
so now you have
here the different peaks there are seven
peaks
and eight different hemoglobin tetramers
is again because two are overlapping
if we look at the birth of the pedigree
you see the the boy the neonate
at 2.5 weeks and three months
and you see his little sister
who's two years old and if you look at
the pattern of the
sister and you look at the pattern of
the father and the mother
it's almost as if the sister has the
passion of mother and father
superimposed
and this is also what happens to the boy
after again three months
he will
look
exactly like his sister
and the good news is that this is not a
bad situation
the combination of having a hemoglobin e
trait with cute thailand doesn't really
matter cute island is is a neutral or
silent hemoglobin variant and the fact
that the boy has an alpha thalassemia
and
a
hemoglobin e which has is a hemoglobin
variant that the beta thalassemia
trait effect
actually the balance becomes again
quite good so this means that there is
no
clinics for these childs
in conclusion what are the key points a
lab should consider in in globality
diagnosis well capillary electrophosis
and hplc or hplc is not enough
it is a combination of
the erectile hematology the hemoglobin
separation and the dna conformation that
makes the diagnosis complete
an elevated hemoglobin a2 is a very good
indicator for beta thalassemia traits
but dna conformation is still important
as not all elevated hemoglobin a2 cases
apparently carry a mutation in the beta
gene
and the only way to find out is
sequencing the beta gene
common hemoglobin variants can be
detected easily both by capillary
electrolysis and hplc
but can only be characterized at the dna
level and then of course
perhaps
the exception is hemoglobin s
hemoglobin s can also be confirmed by
the sickle cell test the positive sickle
cell test is a good indication that it
is really s
also hemoglobin e
the dcip test is done for that in asia
it's very frequently done it's a light
like it gives a turbidity when the
hemoglobin is present
but
alternative tests are
in my opinion not available for
hemoglobin variants
so it is wise to do dna conformation in
those cases
so this means that you have hemo
cytometry you have
capillary electrophoresis and it can be
cbr of course dna
and that would should fit the last
puzzle piece of the clinical diagnosis
if that doesn't fit
there's something you overlooked and you
have to repeat the analysis or look for
special things like copy number
variations
and the alpha genes for instance
i would like to acknowledge
all my collaborators in the netherlands
and abroad thank you very much
hey uh thank you dr harkenville uh for
they got informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
i see we already have a few questions
i'll just go through them in order here
dr harteveld
um
could you uh give some examples about
hemoglobinopathy screening uh this may
have been answered this is a question
from vasam sheraya from kale university
um and i believe what they're asking for
is just the different methodologies of
hemoglobinopathy screening
dr harterville
yeah yes well
there are indeed different forms of
screening in the netherlands we do
neonatal screening and that is uh hplc
screening
so uh the newborn babies they the blood
is collected in goodready cards and then
is dissolved
and it is tested with hplc in this way
it is possible to see carriers of
hemoglobin s
these are also reported
and of course
babies with sickle cell disease
and the screening is mainly to see
disease phenotypes so thalassemia major
and sickle cell disease
however
as as carriers are easily detected these
are reported
to the parents
but it was not the intention of the
screening program the intention was just
to focus on
sickle cell disease
and thoracemia major
other ways of screening carriers
are not organized in the netherlands
that means that it is
just the idea of the midwives for
instance to collaborate
um to see if if they want to discuss
this with their uh
with their patients
so in this way
it is possible for instance if there's
an hemoglobin checkup which is
standard
amongst
pregnant women
you can also
ask for an hplc or a capillary
electrophoresis analysis at the local
lab and in this way carriers can be uh
detected and we try to
promote that this will be discussed at
least with with the pregnant
uh and the
the husband
okay
um moving on to the next question uh we
have a question from michael cicero and
malmonides uh i'm probably saying that
wrong medical center as a teaching
hospital can you remark on h-body seen
when red blood cells are stained
overnight with a supervisal stain
uh when
r slash o hemoglobin h trait or disease
i'm afraid i don't know the r slash o
abbreviation what that stands for yeah
so so the question is if you can see uh
hemoglobin h
um
inclusions
with the uh
brilliant crystal blue staining
well we we do that we do perform this
test
but usually um it is only
to support a dna analysis
so
in the case we see a
let's say
clear microacetic hyperchromic anemia
with a normal a2
and um
we don't find anything on dna level and
still we have a
proper suspicion that it must be alpha
thalassemia then hemoglobin h inclusions
can help
to
to make sure that you have to do for
instance mlpa analysis because then
you are dealing not with a common alpha
thalassemia but with a deletion type or
a rare deletion type
so we use the hemoglobin h inclusion
body test
but mainly to support our dna analysis
okay thank you
um
question from terence agbor from
dynalife diagnostic
uh how does hemoglobin nuac chat run on
acid and alkaline gel electrophoresis
do you happen to know
no no i'm afraid i don't know that but i
think it's an interesting question
because these rare hemoglobin variants
well they can be of course sometimes
missed and you would really like to have
more systems in your
in your
hospital or in your laboratory however
um
we're already quite blessed with the
fact that we have an hplc and a
capillary elective freezes so i can't
ask for more from my
superiority rate
i
in my own just a quick perusal i happen
to know that nuachshot migrates with f
on isoelectric focusing which is roughly
analogous to its position on alkaline
but i'm afraid i don't know where it
migrates on acid
um another question from uh michael
cicero at malmonitis
we use cellulose acetate and citrate
agar to identify are hemoglobinopathies
to date to confirm for example
hemoglobin dg co-migrators under s on
cellulose acetate we submit for alpha
chain analysis to confirm hemoglobin g
until we are approved to upgrade to hplc
what is your opinion of our use of the
current method
well i have no experience with site rate
methods
so so i think what is the most important
thing is that that you're able to to
identify the let's say the most common
ones
and if you have let's say good
experience with the citrate in
combination with other methods i think
it is it is just a very good method
because it indicates that something is
there
however the typing of the hemoglobin
variant is still
debatable i mean there are so many
variants and there's a chance that even
if you use two methods you may not be
able to identify
which hemoglobin variant it really is
so in this case i would recommend dna
analysis
as the following step
okay
another question from the the
same asker
adult pre-op india showed hemoglobin e
disease
siblings the same after study prognosis
so i think this is asking for prognosis
of hemoglobin e homozygous disease
well with hemoglobin e homozygotes um
usually
these are clinically mild so no
treatment is necessary
however if a
pattern shows a hemoglobin e
homozygosity
in a patient which is transfusion
dependent
you may have a beta thalassemia on the
other
part so there is a possibility that that
you
um have an e beta0 towel
in that case
uh the the clinic is much more severe
and these
patients present this beta thalassemia
intermedia so they may
occasionally or regularly need blood
transfusions
at a molecular level they are easily to
distinguish because you usually have
well 95 percent of beta thalassemia as a
point mutation so if you do the
sequencing analysis you will see
heterozygosity for the e-mutation and
uh heterozygosity for an additional beta
thalassemia
a compound heterozygote
but in case you see a homozygous pattern
i would really recommend to do mlpa
analysis in those cases
because then you might have a
combination of a beta-e allele and an
alpha beta0 to have a senior deletion
type
okay thank you for that
um two related questions from theodore
kurtz you ucsf school of medicine
what online resources do you recommend
for databases showing where variants
migrate on capillary
and on hplc
well that is also a very good question
well i know of databases uh uh showing
dna results and hemoglobin var sometimes
also gives some information about
uh the different separation methods of
protein level but um uh what i think is
uh might be useful is the atlas that uh
that cbi has uh is providing to its
clients
uh there you can find a lot of different
patterns
uh in relationship to the um
dna
genotype
so i think i think that that that would
be uh
a way to go
but i i
i know that um ethernet
that is the
database which is uh curated by
uh
by let's say a collaborating
group of experts
that is also quite good up to date but
it does not really
provide
mission you requested so hplc patterns
and capillary electrophoresis would be
very very nice if that would be possible
i should note we are at the top of the
hour here i think we'll be able to
answer a few more
um
there's a question here which i'm
i have encountered hemoglobin i believe
they meant to say hemoglobin f in
infants past six months of age what is
the follow-up and what kind of comments
may be included in the hemoglobin
electrophoresis screening report
so so if i understand well it is an
infant
of
six months old and is expressing just
hemoglobin f
um okay it's a little unclear from the
question i believe they actually said
they have encountered hemoglobin a and
infants past six months of age which of
course would be would be the normal
state
i believe they meant to say hemoglobin f
so a high persistent fetal hemoglobin or
something like that
all right all right
well if you find let's say a high
percentage of hemoglobin f it would
always be
good to to check the parents
because it is an inherited condition so
one of the parents should have showed
the same
or uh if it is for instance due to a
beta thalassemia defect
in homozygosity or compounding to a
zygosity you should see it in the
parents as well but if it is hereditary
persistence of beta hemoglobin or hpfh
one of the parents should be carrier at
least so i think
it is important
to do either dna
confirmation or dna diagnosis on these
cases using mlpa for the beta cluster to
determine hpf h deletions
or if their deletions are not present
the gamma promoter sequences just to
detect the non-deletion type of hpfh
which are in fact quite rare
delta b thalassemia deletions are much
more common in this respect
everything is relative of course
but um
if you think that the hemoglobin f is uh
due to a um
let's say
disease related mechanism
so not hpf h but
actually disease related so
just f expression for instance in in a
small child
it's very likely that it is uh
beta thalassemia major and i think in
that case screening of the parents would
be very helpful
um a question about a particularly
sticky issue uh from claudine bates
central laboratories bayley road
can you please explain the new drug
voxelotor
why this drug interferes with our
capillary hemoglobin assay
ah well
i have no experience with that
so it's very well i can't speculate on
that i'm afraid sorry
any advice for diagnosing beta-style
trait in newborns
this is from maria
the hairy medical
yeah that's a very good point um
at birth the a2 is not visible so for a
newborn it is not possible to to look
for elevated a2
if you would like to have a screening
like that
it is either on
dna level but then you
lack actually the information
of the hplc because that is not really
or capillary electrophoresis because
that is not
showing anything
another possibility would be to screen
children at the age of one year
or older and this way you could
see the elevated a2 of course easily
and
if you don't want to
screen children because well at that age
maybe it is not relevant yet to detect
carriers
then you could decide to
or uh to to screen
um
children or let's say adolescence
uh at school age
and that is something which is done in
italy uh
there's of course a high
incidence of beta thalassemia
and um
already in the 60s
uh school children were were screened
with permission of their parents
um
to see if the they have elevated a2 and
now therefore carry over beta telecinia
so that let's say advice could be given
during biology lessons
um question from gilean paina from
nsbmb the cdc
when using capillary or hplc were
sampled screens or tested in liquid
blood or instead were dried blood spots
used
well we use only liquid bloods
but
but the neonatal screening in the
netherlands is all dried blood spots
um question from
anupam basu uh if alpha and beta i
believe variants co-associate what will
be the clinical outcome
well actually if the
alpha and beta
mutations of course let's say an
expression defect so alpha thalassemia
reduced expression of alpha and beta
mutation and decreased expression of the
beta
then actually you you restore the
balance
so if if the
if you have a double carrier of an alpha
thalassemia and the beta thalassemia
what you see is
a higher red blood cell count and
a somewhat lower mcb and mch but
generally the hemoglobin level is quite
okay it's let's say at the border of
a low hemoglobin
it's not a pathological condition
okay
um
from terence agbor dinolights
a few months ago there was a cap
challenge consisting of high affinity
hemoglobins heathrow malmo and olympia
etc
it's difficult to distinguish these
variants by hplc and capillary
electrophoresis do you happen to know
how these variants migrate in gel
electrophoresis acid alkaline we will
run our hemoglobinopathies with ce then
reflex to gel electrophoresis
i see well
i have little experience with the
electrophoresis um
as as you as you do that
so i can only compare the hplc with the
capillary electrophoresis and yes
sometimes it happens that you can't see
one
uh an hb variant with one method but if
you see it with the other it's really
no problem as long as you do dna
confirmation
yes it should also likely be noted the
high affinity hemoglobins won't
necessarily behave the same way in
capillary or hplc with one another so
heathrow malmo and olympia may migrate
very differently
yes um
does your laboratory keep inventory of
different variants what kinds of samples
does the lab perform stability on the
samples over time this is a question
from gillian paina at the cdc
um
well we we don't do really tests on on
stability of of the hemoglobins we if we
find the hemoglobin variant
sometimes we search the
collaboration with another lab who is
less more let's say more specialized in
in
studying proteins because i'm working in
a genetic department so the fact that
i'm
looking at protein levels is quite
exceptional for my colleagues who
look upon me as a i'm coming from mars
or something
so if if we really want to have more
knowledge about
the hemoglobin protein and and about its
stability then then we have to look uh
outside outside our departments and then
the collaboration with the
labs in paris for instance from harvey
weitmann in the past has been very
very useful
okay
um question from uh patrick trellat from
toso what about the significance and
accuracy of the a2 value in case of
hemoglobin s
or variant in the hplc technique and
capillary technique is it correct to
report this a2 value
well hemoglobin a2 values are of course
important to distinguish the beta
thalassemia carrier from a non-carrier
but
one should be cautious
because
um as i have shown him in in the graph
uh between the group of normal a2 and
the group of elevated a2 usually there's
a quite a distinction between normal a2
and elevated a2 but there are also
certain mutations which only elevate the
a2
marginally so so this means that there
is a certain overlap between the normal
distribution of normal a2 and elevated
a2
so i think
it is it's important to measure the a2
as accurate as possible but you can
never rely on one method
whether it's hplc or capillary
electrophoresis i understand that the
screening lab has to take to have a
needs arrange and cut off
but of course a screening lab
takes into account that it will
possibly misdiagnose a certain
percentage of cases simply because it is
let's say
one of those beta thalassemia mutations
which go with the hardly elevated a2
and if that is very common in the
population
they really should be very careful
what would
cut off range is important
so i think it is important to have an
accurate a2 and of course that is the
reason why the world is working hard to
have a standardization for hemoglobin a2
but on the other hand we have to take
into account that you can never rely on
a single method
all right and we have uh one last
question she closed out i believe uh
from gillian payne cdc will you be able
to share the slide deck
i don't i don't know if we had if you
had planned on making your slide deck
available uh beyond just the recording
of this presentation
i think my my slides are are available
and and the recording as well as i
understood from cbi i have no problem
with that
okay okay
um i believe that is the last of the
questions we have uh thank you very much
for your time and for coming back to
answer these questions after the
recorded presentation
um i believe uh i believe we'll close
out now thank you very much uh dr
hartsville
okay thank you very much